hey sweet top G well um what do you guys
think of Andrew Tate
I don't mind Andrew Tate I just don't
really like his followers I really don't
have a problem with Andrew Tate I think
if you are a successful man who does
well and you understand the Dynamics of
men and women he's become Muslim now as
well which is I'm Muslim so anyone that
becomes a Muslim I'm like go and then um
so yeah so um you know any I don't have
a problem with him he's obviously
speaking from his own lived experience
and this is how he gets women to behave
around him but he is a successful man he
works out he's got money he's got all of
these things so he can talk with his
chairs what I don't like is that nobody
kind of guy that follows him and then
starts adopting all his values and
starting having this really angry
attitude towards women and be like and
that's what it almost you think he's
angry not him but I think his followers
aren't what's Andrew takes values to you
uh what do you mean by that like because
you said they adopt his values okay your
values as in like oh women aren't like
this is how you should treat women This
Is How They this is what women like this
is how do you get them to submit this is
what you do but you can you can get that
level of submission when you're that
level of guy but if she's not submitting
to you you're either aiming too high or
you're not successful enough as a man
yeah but then he says get more
successful
do you think it's okay for him to say yo
get make a [ __ ] ton of money so you can
[ __ ] a lot of hoes yeah no but I think
that the fact that the guys are taking
on what he's saying about women but not
taking on what he's saying about
business and earning potential and
working out and paying for women are all
these things a lot of them do do you
think so the ones I see in these
comments are the new I I just don't I
see it as like just people if you did
have a lifestyle like Andrew Tate you
wouldn't be so angry against women a man
that's angry against women can't get
women to submit to them and that's what
fuels their anger so I feel like don't
think they're angry I think they just
have standards like I just I mean we're
talking in general right I just like I
just think they say things like like
they don't want a girl with a low body
count they don't want a girl that's fat
they don't want to but they've got it
like that don't need to say it like that
yeah so you know the men that have the
men that I know that have these
standards never need to vocalize it and
never need to watch a podcast on it it's
interesting I I would agree with you but
I've met good looking guys that make
good money that have left the us to go
to a different country and they just say
it's better yeah they say I'll get two
matches in the US and then I'll get 130
in Poland right
yeah I guess the culture of the women
makes it really difficult to submit but
I genuinely think when you are a man of
value you don't need to follow any man
telling you what to do and also you
don't have an angry attitude towards
women women just like when you're a
woman of value when you're a woman who
gets men uh treating her well you don't
be you're not screaming men are trash
you're not angry against men you don't
have those attitudes because to you men
have always been good similarly if you
find men with high value they don't
experience these type of women who are
running games on them cheating on them
talking out the side of their mouths to
them they don't experience
is the number one reason we can agree
NBA players get [ __ ] right the number
one reason they go broke is getting the
wrong [ __ ] you're pregnant yeah because
they choose badly but if you're a real a
man of high standards you don't choose
badly yeah the vetting process Jeff
Bezos yeah
a high value man has it just like you
said I value because he picked the wrong
number but just like you were saying
nice girls don't get with bad boys men
of value can spot a thought from a mile
off and it's that simple you can spot a
thought that's one of your skills as a
masculine man Alpha men don't tolerate
promiscuity I think I think they don't
have promiscuous women in their lives
the new thoughts
um whatever's your level how many bodies
I would say I mean I I've got because by
19. so I've got a very different version
zero minus figures
1950s 40 standards it's like two I've
got a very different standard because of
my culture and my religion so I can't
really speak on other people I really
can't
um and so but what I would say is one of
the definitions of an alpha man is you
don't tolerate promiscuity and you vet
women before they come into your world
you don't let any old riff raff in your
house and if you do then you're not
you're not high value just because
you've got money and you've got status
that in itself is not enough you've got
to have levels to it and the levels to
it is you don't let any Riff Raff I I
agree with you on the point that you
know I do think men should vet women
yeah and I do you think men should have
high standards yeah where I disagree
with you is I I think it's silly to say
that you a girl can't trick a guy I
think even if he's Alpha even if he's
high value even if he has this this and
this like I think can you trick a good
woman
yeah
no I agree no you can't so what I would
say is if you have especially with these
NBA players most of their women have
like their bodies out on Instagram and
then this that and the other and this
and then and then if you can't spot from
that then you are not high value what
about what about like what about like
Tom Brady's wife uh Giselle do you think
do you think she was a walking red flag
I just think um Victoria's Secret it
depends what you I think is again that
my values are a little bit skewed
because I'm Muslim but the thing is if
your woman sells her body and that's her
primary source of income she's going to
have more liberal values and when you
bring a woman with liberal values into
your home you have to expect liberal
outcomes that's all so even Tom Brady
you're dating a Victoria's Secret model
who makes a money out of her body and
there's nothing wrong with that but
you've got to recognize with that comes
different types of values and so yeah do
you think then he's not Alpha yeah
so you think Tom Brady is not high value
any man who allows promiscuity and that
kind of uh to mother his children I
don't believe it's Alpha because Alpha
men are so protective they're so
possessive they don't even risk the idea
of kokodri the idea of their woman
having potential this is if we're
talking evolutionary psychology sense
the alpha man in the pack is my woman
can never go with another man because
I'm not wasting my money or my resources
on somebody else's kid now if you take
that risk in any way shape or form you
lose some of your Alpha you've got to
remember babies happen
which I mean like you could it could
just be like one of your side things a
girl that you're buying and baby happens
I actually think that your your
minimizing the fact that we live in a
different Society so women in the
western Society have a different mindset
than women elsewhere so what you're
saying would work in so many other
places in the world but it wouldn't work
in the west yeah maybe because I'm from
Pakistan and my culture if you even have
one body count you're right off you're
just a write-off and it's that and any
man that does go with you he's then seen
in a lower way so maybe my mentality is
obviously skewed from that but I can
still think it applies even when you're
I mean a guy can get a perfect girl like
she could be a virgin and she could
still turn like she could still wish she
could still turn 28. she could still
turn 28 29 and and say oh you know at
the last the last 10 years I've been
missing out and leave him but chances
are less that you're you're right the
chances are from this you're you're
right the chances are less but then does
that make that guy not Alpha that
doesn't make sense the thing is he did
his safety took a 21 year old who then
decided at 28 to become you know
whatever she wants he did his betting by
choosing selected when he chose her he
chose right but if you're choosing a
girl at 22 who's been you know doing the
most and then wanting her to become a
wife you lose your Alpha because part of
your Alpha is full sight you can spot
what's gonna be the good mother of your
child if you don't have that full set
you lose your Alpha I just I just think
you're you're minimizing men's
experiences by by making it that gen
like that broad how come when it came to
the women because because women are
because women are born with value men
must create it yeah and so like a woman
loses her value when she dates a bad boy
right but a man doesn't lose his Alpha
just because he picked the wrong girl I
think but for me if I'm dating a guy and
I see that his ex was you know maybe had
a really promiscuous past I can't [ __ ]
with him
because you've got standards that aren't
my level because you'll go for anyone
then and I lose but I think in Brady's
case like yeah there's a lot of girls
that for me that won't date Drake now
because I wouldn't date a guy that's
been like you know I've been with a
certain girl because I'm just like
that's your level because that's your
level you wouldn't date Drake
uh I don't know if Jake would rate me
and that was all I needed to know that
was all I needed to know no no no no no
no
God
no but it's not you know what it's okay
because you like the thing about our
series no okay honestly I don't think
any woman it depends what kind of woman
she is but personally if you're a little
woman that's looking for a long-term
relationship there's no point dating
Drake so so no but that's not you're
saying I wouldn't date him you're saying
I wouldn't date him because he's not
looking for something serious because it
makes no sense too
long long time
that's what I'm saying you're not saying
I wouldn't date him you're saying I
wouldn't date him because he wouldn't
take me long term I wouldn't do any one
where I can't see the that person
settling down and creating a life with
me why would I date you but the reason
why Drake is probably a bad boy is
because he's going to tell you that he's
going to be there for the long term and
you're going to believe it but even
Drake's baby mama was a porn star and
stuff to me that makes him lose value no
but you still would date him so he
didn't lose too much value
and that's the thing like like yeah but
this is why like like I'm just this is
what I I used to think a lot like you
yeah but this is why like a lot of times
men will say don't take dating advice
from women because we don't even know
what we want but you do you think a man
who's got a past of women that are all
like promiscuous or whatever it is if
you could go out and they're a certain
way all of his exes does that not put
you off him a bit no but you moved the
goal post who's talking about one
relationship and why you're talking
about anyone that's got a past on making
bad choices is a bad choice man or woman
right so if a man or if all these exes
yeah escorts then you just kind of
looking at the type of guy if all if all
the guys they say Tom Brady isn't
it you know why she left him she left
him because he said he wanted to go back
and get another ring that's why she left
him and she wanted him to to retire and
now to be at home but you have to
understand you've gone your job as a
woman is your pit
hold on a second you've picked one of
the top like percents of athletes like
that you're not going to get another Tom
Brady's like having a LeBron James and
then he said you know what I'm not ready
to go yet I still got some more fighting
me so you said you know what I wanted to
retire so I want to now divorce you
that's a selfish thing because your job
as a wife is supposed to support him he
his career isn't finished you might have
thought it was finished but he's in the
Finish he still got more to give so you
divorce him because you say that you
know what this is not what we agreed and
I want to be able to start to live my
life that's a selfish you know what as
soon as she dated Leonardo DiCaprio you
should have known anyway man
what do you think about men who take
pictures of their women that are making
only fans and they're the ones filming
it for her to post
okay I'm not saying it's irrelevant I'm
asking what you think about does it
reduce his masculinity right having a
promiscuous woman does what produces
your mask so have you wait you've
equated to just picking a woman that you
might break up with to having a dunoon
only fans and taking pictures of a booty
that's generally having a Association
the point is you keep moving yeah I'm
confused but also I don't I don't think
it reduces his masculinity because I
think a man who posts his who posts
pictures of his woman online is a pimp
masculine
that's where he is I don't think you'd
marry a woman that would be posting or
having an only fans and stuff and if he
did it's still to me it would reduce
your masculinity part of masculinity
isn't just money and appearance it's
also protectiveness of your women that's
an interesting that the um
I'll explain to you why because the
truth is really and truly the most
successful pimps are a different
archetype of man so most times a pimp
has full control over that woman so
that's a masculine trait in in some ways
which is now labeled toxic masculinity
right yeah but that's like the extreme
of masculinity but like you're looking
at it from like men can lose their Alpha
absolutely because that's where that's
at a different like
like women are you're looking at it from
a woman's point of view because women
have value and they lose it if if a man
is in the top two percent of men one
percent of men I I don't think he can
lose them lose his I don't think Drake
wait let me finish I don't think Drake
loses his Alpha because he's [ __ ] a
lot of hoes and I think you might you
may be in your culture you personally
but I don't think most girls are gonna
have any issue dating Drake because he
had a baby with a corn star no but with
evolutionary psychology which is defines
the whole of the time part of
masculinity is providing and protecting
protecting means protecting her from
other men that's what protecting means
in masculine terms and when you have a
promiscuous woman that means you either
she's promiscuous before or after you
whatever it is that protection element
isn't there enough and that's what I
mean by that because if you cannot be a
masculine man with that that protective
quality you can't a man that doesn't
protect women is not masculine now part
of that protection is making sure no
other man can access that woman because
that's my womb that's my baby that's my
oven now if you don't have if you don't
exercise with that mentality you lose
your masculinity it's how human nature
is defined I think your view is kind of
skewed due to your like culture I'll
just I was thinking we live in a UK
issue biological
Let's Take My Religion out of it if
we're talking about men living in
pre-historic evolutionary let's take
even before this protecting all the
hosts yeah but let's take even let's say
for example we live in a jungle society
and you need to make sure that you're
getting resources for your kids and only
your kids if you've got a woman that's
doing the most you could be feeding kids
that aren't yours so you won't survive
your survival is reduced yeah but
they're biologically predispositioned to
spread their seed to everybody not to
look after everybody else's kids they
don't want to look after anything yeah
yeah so that's why you don't choose a
promiscuous I don't think they should
choose a promiscuous woman what I'm
arguing with you is you say because
someone chooses the wrong woman they're
not Alpha yeah absolutely
absolutely like you lose like but again
like again babies happen right yeah so
it doesn't mean you lose your your alpha
male that's that status because you've
breeded up the wrong girl look Pearl if
you have if a girl if a woman has the
baby by the wrong guy she's a feminine
woman she's still a feminine woman off
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible